[Music]
one of the important and for many
readers very memorable characters of
ursula kayla green's fourth earthy novel
to hanu is anti-moss and moss is a
village witch a woman of some power and
somebody who is going to become closely
connected with tenar and her adopted
daughter theroux and with ged also
connected with ogian since they live in
the same place and moss views him as
by contrast to so many other mages and
wizards a very
kind and gentle man somebody who who's
good and treats her well
so what is a village witch we should
start there and there's a description
that's provided
in this
village witches though they may know
many spells and charms and some of the
great songs were never trained in the
high arts or principles of majory no
woman was so trained women wizardry was
a man's work a man's skill magic was
made by
men and in in this book we find out
there had never been a woman mage though
some few had called themselves wizard or
sorceress their power had been untrained
strength without outer knowledge half
frivolous half dangerous now we know
from the later
stories and novels that that's not quite
true and there was also an enchantress
at rayalbe just up the road but
witches are a a pretty common phenomena
across
not just the isle of god but earthsea
and leguin continues and says the
ordinary village witch like moss lived
on a few words of the true speech handed
down as great treasures from older
witches or bought at high cost from
sorcerers and a supply of common spells
of finding and mending much meaningless
ritual and mystery making in gibberish a
solid experiential training in midwifery
bone setting curing animal and human
ailments a good knowledge of herbs mixed
with a mess of superstitions all this
built up on whatever native gift
she might have of healing chanting
changing or spell casting such a mixture
might be a good one or a bad one some
witches were fierce bitter women ready
to do harm knowing no reason not to do
harm
most were midwives and healers with a
few love potions fertility charms and
potency spells on the side and a good
deal of quiet cynicism about them a few
having wisdom though no learning used
their gift purely for good though they
could not tell as an apprentice wizard
could the reason for which what they did
and prayed of the balance and the way of
power to justify their abstention or
action
and so this is you know
interesting starting point for thinking
about what these village witches are we
know you know of them already from a
wizard of earthsea where ged's uh aunt
was a witch and taught him a number of
names and then uh he he winds up being
apprenticed to ogean
and there's also a back story an
important backstory at least
for moss about how she
wound up in the village because she
wasn't actually
from there and this comes up while she
antenna are discussing
uh wizardry and sexuality and things
that we're going to get to
in a bit
and
here's here's the description
moas says
um
i was crazy for a man here for a long
time ago a good looking man but a cold
hard heart
uh
but i was i was so heart set on him i
did use my art i spent many a charm on
him but it was all wasted i came up here
to ray albee in the first place when i
was a girl because i was in trouble with
a man in gantt port
but i can't talk of that for they were
rich great folks twas they that had the
power not i they didn't want their son
tangled with a common girl like me foul
[ __ ] they called me and they'd have had
me put out of the way like killing a cat
if i hadn't run off up here but oh i did
like that lad with his round smooth arms
and legs and his big dark eyes i can see
him playing his plane after all these
years so
she was you know a local girl in ganport
already probably a witch she had some
power
got involved with a a man from a rich
family they didn't like that they
threatened to kill her probably
a baby as well
and she goes on up to realby doesn't go
to the manor house of course but just to
the village and that's where she stays
we also find out that tennar
had encountered
moss quite a long time ago when tenor
had first lived in rayalbi 25 years ago
moss had not been an old witch but a
young one
she had ducked and bowed and grinned at
the young lady the white lady ogian's
ward and student never speaking to her
but with the utmost respect
tener had felt that respect to be false
a mask for an envy and dislike and
distrust that were all too familiar to
her from women over whom she'd been
placed in a position of superiority
women who saw themselves as common in
her as uncommon as privileged priestess
of the tombs of ottawan or foreign war
to the mage of god she was set apart
said above
men had given her power men had shared
their power with her women looked at her
from outside sometimes rival wrists
often with a trace of ridicule she'd
felt herself to be the one left outside
shut out
and so you know moss was was part of
that as well moss fit in
better as much as a witch can fit in
and so that's you know
a good
back story and and
sort of thumbnail sketch of what witches
are like now
moss is going to be a very helpful
person in her own ways of course she's
going to help
tenner with ogean with theroux and with
ged in important ways and she'll also
communicate what she has of her own
wisdom
to tenor
so first ogian dies and
moss is the one as village witches are
accustomed to do who handles his what's
called homing and there's a description
of it here
brief one
auntie moss unmarried like most witches
unwashed with graying hair tied and
curious charm knots eyes read him from
herb smoke she had come across the
meadow with the lantern and with tenor
and the others she'd watched the night
by ogien's body this is the homing she'd
set a wax candle and a glass shade there
in the forest and burned sweet oils in a
dish of clay she said the words that
should be said and done what should be
done when it came to touching the body
to prepare it for burial she looked at
once to ten hours of her permission and
then gone on with her offices village
witches usually sought of the homing as
they called it of the dead and often to
the burial then the two wizards come one
from the manor house and one from the
port of gaunt and then they're both
basically trying to take over the
ceremony and tenor says
i was the one who was his ward i know
that he wants to be buried here i'm the
one who actually knows his name and
they're not paying attention to her
because she's a woman and then moss
who's scurried away when the wizards
show up actually interrupts them saying
loudly yes she was she was nobody else
but her he sent for her he sent young
townsend the sheep dealer to tell her to
come clear around the mountain and he
waited his dying till she did come and
was with him then he died and he died
where he would be buried here so moss is
sticking up for ogian and for tenor
and with thero there's there's something
else that's going on
um
and i'm going to actually read another
line this is quite important since she
and moss kept the vigil for ogin
together the witch had made it plain she
would be tenar's friend followers
followers servant whatever tenor wanted
her to be
tener was not at all sure what she
wanted auntie moss to be finding her
unpredictable unreliable
incomprehensible passionate ignorant sly
and dirty
but moss got on with the burned child
perhaps it was moss who is working this
change this slight easing in theru with
her thero behaved as with everyone
blank unanswering docile and the way an
inanimate thing a stone is docile but
the old woman had kept at her offering
her little sweets and treasures bribing
coaxing weedling come with auntie moss
now deary come along and anti-muscle
show you the prettiest sight you ever
saw and tenor reflects that you know in
the stories about witches this might
lead to being in an oven or something
like that but in the case of
of thero
moss is actually showing her all sorts
of things she's
educating her in her environment and in
what she can do
with her body a prime
example
of this
is where
it says nothing theroux did or said
showed she was learning anything from
anti-moss except for the lark nested and
the blueberries grew and how to make
cat's cradles one-handed thero's right
hand had been so eaten by fire it had
healed into a kind of club the thumb
usable only as a pincer like a crab's
claw
but auntie moss had an amazing set of
cat's cradles
for four fingers and a thumb and rhymes
to go with the figures
churn churn cherry all burn burn berry
all come dragon [ __ ] and the string would
form four triangles that flicked into a
square
so you know cat's cradle of course is
the child's game where you have a string
and you make different figures with it
moss is helping pharaoh to to develop to
grow in a way that maybe tener can't
completely
do herself
another line she was kind of thera but
it was a weedling kindness and when they
were together it seemed she talked to
the child a great deal tenner did not
know what moss was telling her teaching
her whether she should let the witch
fill the child's head with stuff
and they bring up this this
very important line weak as woman's
magic wicked as woman's magic she'd
heard a hundred times
so you know maybe there's something bad
going on maybe there's something good
going on when it comes to ged
after tennar has him delivered to her by
khaleesian the oldest of all dragons and
she brings god down she needs some help
and auntie moss and heather help her get
ged who seems to be perhaps dying
into uh ogian's bed and they nurse and
tend him there and moss is on the alert
she says this isn't the same guy he
doesn't have any
wizardly powers he's not a mage at all
so be on guard maybe he's a gabeth maybe
he's a trickster we don't know what's
going on and moss actually kind of hopes
that he's going to die but he doesn't
die
later moss will actually offer ged
sanctuary in her place when ged is
trying to hide from the king's men who
are wanting to bring him as the ark mage
which he no longer feels himself to be
to the the king
and moss will also send him on his way
when he goes south to become a goat
herder once again
with some bread and some cheese some
provisions for
the road
tener sees the effects of all of this
and she and moss have a
important friendship that that develops
and they have some very interesting
conversations
in which tener is going to learn
something and moss is very convinced of
her point of view she's putting forth
something leguin is having moss as a
character say some things that are very
attractive to some people when it comes
to all these key topics of witches and
wizards magic power and sexuality
but it's not actually representative of
[Music]
leguin's position
as much as tenor's point of view is
and so you know we we get some uh
important teachings here's one
tener says auntie how do you tell if a
man's a wizard or not
moss's reply was circuitous beginning
with the usual nomics and obscurities
deep nose deep she said deeply and once
born will speak and she told a story
about an ant that picked up a tiny end
of hair from the floor of a palace and
ran off to the ants nest with it and in
the night the nest glowed underground
like a star for the hair was from the
head of the great mage broast but only
the wise could see the glowing ant hill
to common eyes it was dark
one needs training then said tenar maybe
maybe not was the gist of moss's dark
reply some are born with that gift even
when they don't know it it will be there
like the hair of the mage and the hole
in the ground it will shine
and then she says well how do you know
if a man's not a wizard and she says
it's not there it's not there deary the
power
i've got eyes in my head i can see that
you have eyes right if you're blind i'll
see that
if you've only got one eye or like the
little one or if you've got three i'll
see them won't i but i if i don't have
an eye to see with i won't know till you
do tell me but i do i see i know the
third eye she touched her forehead and
gave a loud dry chuckle she was pleased
with having found the words to say what
she wanted to say
a good deal of her obscurity and cant
tenure had began to realize was mere
ineptness with words and ideas nobody
had ever taught her to think
consecutively
nobody had ever listened to what was
said all that was expected all that was
wanted of her was muddle mystery
mumbling she was a witch woman she had
nothing to do with clear
meaning
and so you know she she goes on and they
they talk about power and wizardry and
then moss says something very
interesting
she says
the best i can say is like this about
men a man's in his skin see like a nut
in its shell it's hard and strong that
shell and it's full all full of him full
of grand man meat man self and that's
all that's all there is it's all him and
nothing else inside
ten are pondered a while and said but if
he's a wizard
then it's all his power inside his
powers himself see that's how it is with
him and that's all when his power is
gone he's gone empty
nothing
and a woman then and here's where moss
says one of the lines that has been
repeated so many times about this book
oh well dearie a woman's a different
thing entirely who knows where a woman
begins and ends
listen mistress i have roots i have
roots deeper than this island deeper
than the sea older than the raising of
the lands i go back into the dark
moss's eyes shown with a weird
brightness and their red rims and her
voice sang like an instrument i go back
into the dark before the moon i was no
one knows no one knows no one can say
what i am what a woman is a woman of
power a woman's power deeper than the
roots of trees deeper than the roots of
islands older than the making older than
the moon who dares ask questions of the
dark hole asked the dark its name
the old woman was rocking chanting lost
in her incantation
but tenor sat upright
i will
i've lived long enough in the dark
and so what we have here is
moss putting forth this you know very
in some respects grandiose view of what
it is to be a woman roots that go down
forever into the dark and can't be
brought into the light as a result a
little bit later when she's talking
about
wizards and witches again and she's
talking about power she will tell us
that um
a wizard is like a great
you know pine tree something very
visible
but it can get blown down whereas a
witch
women in general are like blackberry
thickets their roots are not going to be
pulled up by any wind whatsoever they
don't go as high
and they may have thorns rather than
needles
but they're much more durable
there's also some interesting
discussions as we've already mentioned
about sexuality
and mosque is very interested in uh um
tenor's account of the eunuchs right
um
she she asked do they take him and do
them like rams and he goats like that
with a gelding knife
horror the macabre and a gleam of
vengeance had won out over both anger
and reason moss didn't want to pursue
any topic but that of unix
tenor could not tell her much she
realized she'd never thought about the
matter when she was a girl in otto and
they'd been gelded men and one of them
had loved her tenderly and she him and
she'd killed him to escape from him then
she'd come to the archipelago where
there were no eunuchs and forgotten them
sunk them in darkness with manon's
body
and a little bit later they they also
talk about um
come to back to the sexuality
part as well and
here we go
so
moss
talking about ged says it's a queer
thing for an old man to be a boy of 15
no doubt
tenor also almost said what are you
talking about moss
something prevented her she realized
she'd been listening for ged to come
back
ah she said a great many thoughts
suddenly coming to her mind all at once
that's why she said that's why i never
after a long silence she said do they do
wizards as a spell
surely surely dear he said moss they
witch themselves some will tell you they
make a trade-off like marriage turned
backward with vows and all and so get
their power then but to me that's got a
wrong sound to like a dealing with the
old powers more than a true what a true
witch deals with and the old mage he
told me they did no such thing though i
have known some women witches do it and
come to no great harm by it the ones who
brought me up tenor says did that
promising virginity
oh i no men you told me and them eunuchs
terrible but why but why did i never
think then the witch says because that's
the power of a dairy you don't think you
can't and nor do they once they've set
their spell how could they given their
power it wouldn't do it wouldn't do
you don't get without you give as much
that's true for all so they know the
which men the men of power they know
that better than any but you know it's
an uneasy man for a man it's an easy
thing for a man not to be a man no
matter if he can call the sun down from
the sky and so they put it right out of
mind with their spells of binding and
truly so
i've never heard of a wizard breaking
these spells seeking to use his power
for his body's lust even the worst would
fear to
and um
tener says they set themselves apart aye
a woman a wizard has to do that but you
don't me i'm only a witch woman dearie
and she says but
you haven't been celibate what's that
teary like the wizards oh no no no
never was anything to look at but there
was a way i could look at them not
witching you know dearie but you know
what i mean there's a way to look and
he'd come around sure as a crow will
call
i knew what it was they needed if i
liked them well enough maybe they got it
as for love for love i'm not one of them
though you know some witches are but
they dishonor the art i do my art for
pay but i take my pleasure for love so
women of power don't have to be
celibates
men of power have to give up their
sexuality and that's what ged in fact
did and that's why tenor realizes they
never became as we would say
an item
the last thing that we have to talk
about is that moss is used by the wicked
wizard aspen of rey alby as bait to try
to lure
tennar and uh thero he actually ends up
getting gad in
and what we find is theroux runs to
anti-moss
and she says who's there who's there oh
deary my per my little burned one my
pretty what are you doing here where's
your mother
did did she come don't come in don't
come in dearie there's a curse on me he
cursed the old woman don't come near me
there who puts out her hand and touches
her and she says don't look at me he
made my flesh rot and shrivel and rot
again but he won't let me die he said
i'd bring you here i tried to die i
tried but he held me he held me living
against my will he won't let me die
theroux says you shouldn't die
and she says child the old woman
whispered dearie call me by my name
hatha the child said i knew set me free
dearie and
thero says i have to wait till they come
till who come deary my people
the witch's big cold hand lay like a
bundle of sticks in hers she held it
firmly it was dark now
outside the hut as in it hotha who was
called moss slept and presently the
child sitting on the floor beside her
cot with a hen perch nearby slept also
so theroux now is able to return the
the care and the nursing
that moss has has given to her
and in the end moss will be saved
fortunately there's more to be told to
the story but this is enough about i
think this important character anti-moss
who represents a certain
way of understanding all of these
important topics the relation between
men and women magic and power and
sexuality and good and evil
you